jeder hat sie und irgendwie kommt man
auch nicht drum herum die guten alten
weihnachtstraditionen für manche ist es
der gefüllte gänsebraten mit rotkohl und
klößen nämlich fehlen darf für andere
ist es der serien marathon nach der
bestellung aber nicht nur auf weiten
teilen dieser welt wird weihnachten
gefeiert sondern auch in welt als zum
beispiel auf der internationalen
raumstation iss oder woanders wird
woanders opfer ich weiß nicht ob die
besatzung einen tannenbaum geschmückt
wie genau die bescherung dort aussieht
und was star wars mit den festtagen im
weltraum zu tun hat jetzt in science
fiction mit unserer sonderedition zu
weihnachten herzlich willkommen also und
frohe weihnachten ja mitte dezember
haben sich drei neuen raumfahrer zur iss
auf gemacht quasi driving home for
christmas in gewisser weise oder driving
home for christmas die sojus rakete mit
den amerikanischen astronauten scott
kinkel und neuschnee kann und dem
kosmonauten anton stapel leerer war am
letzten sonntag vom russischen
weltraumbahnhof baikonur in kasachstan
gestartet als möglicher ersatzmann war
übrigens der deutsche alexander gerst am
start am dienstag hat die soli sms 07
dann an der iss angedockt heißt also
weihnachten und silvester auf da ss und
tatsächlich würde sind 400 kilometern
höhe richtig weihnachtlich laut einer
russischen agentur meldung gibt es
tatsächlich einen tannenbaum eine
russische zeitung schreibt dass der
sogar dauerhaft auf der iss eingelagert
ist macht ja auch in gewisser weise sind
schließlich wiederholt sich weihnachten
in regelmäßigen abständen auch wenn es
immer überraschen kommt aber sogar ein
zweiter baum ist wohl in planung und
soll
doch schon mit einem us raumtransporter
zur iss gelangt sein fehlen also nur
noch die geschenke für eine feierliche
bescherung und die wird wohl ein
russischer frachter zur iss bringen
sowohl von den familien des teams als
auch von roskosmos und der nasa und
jetzt noch zu einem sehr wichtigen
bestandteil von weihnachten dem essen
selbst das weihnachtsfest wird nichts
daran ändern dass es das menü aus
alufolie und konserven gibt was konkret
aufgetischt wird ist noch nicht bekannt
in den letzten jahren gab es so was wie
truthahn grüne bohnen kartoffeln
schokoladenkuchen und fruchtsalat fest
steht jedenfalls die astronauten werden
achtung jetzt kommt den neuen star wars
film
auf der iss sehen dürfen ja der plan der
nasa der film wird über das space center
in texas zwei ss hochgeladen
da wär ich echt gern dabei und es werden
die tradition aus allen teilen der welt
mit eingebracht in den bevorstehenden
feiertagen
denn es sind ja neben den drei us
amerikaner und in dem japaner auch noch
zwei russische besatzungsmitglieder am
start und das orthodoxe weihnachtsfest
am 7 januar gefeiert früher gab es dazu
dann schon einmal eine botschaft eines
moskauer patriarchen an die crew
so oder so es wird jedenfalls festlich
in den letzten jahren gab es auch immer
mal wieder ziemlich kitschige
weihnachtsdeko in 400 kilometern höhe
das zeigen beweisfotos der cruze und im
hintergrund weihnachts strümpfe lametta
und rote santa clause mützen 2012 hatte
der kanadische astronaut chris redfield
sogar seine gitarre dabei und dann steht
ja noch silvester an wann feiern die das
eigentlich und wie oft hallo wer kann
das recherchieren und in die kommentare
schreiben
auf jeden fall wird auch auf der iss
angestoßen neben den ganzen partys gibt
es aber auch eine menge zu tun
auf dem programm für nächstes jahr
stehen mehr als 250 experimente und zwar
in sachen technik medizin und biologie
anfang des neuen jahres wird dann zudem
wird es verschiedene außeneinsätze geben
tja und wenn er davon nichts verpassen
wollt dann sollten wir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergessen ich dem genau auf
die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
sonneneruptionen bedrohen die iss also
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran vor
weihnachten und so weiter und so fort
und bleibt friedlich